The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Starting
with a differential equation.
So key point here
in this lecture
is how do you start with
a differential equation
and end up with a discrete
problem that you can solve?
But simple
differential equation.
It's got a second derivative and
I put a minus sign for a reason
that you will see.
Second derivatives are
essentially negative
definite things so that
minus sign is to really
make it positive definite.
And notice we have
boundary conditions.
At one end the solution is zero,
at the other end it's zero.
So this is fixed-fixed.
And it's a boundary
value problem.
That's different from an
initial value problem.
We have x space, not time.
So we're not starting
from some thing
and oscillating or growing
or decaying in time.
We have a fixed thing.
Think of an elastic bar.
An elastic bar
fixed at both ends,
maybe hanging by its own weight.
So that load f(x) could
represent the weight.
Maybe the good place
to sit is over there,
there are tables
just, how about that?
It's more comfortable.
So we can solve that equation.
Especially when I
change f(x) to be one.
As I plan to do.
So I'm going to
change, I'm going
to make it-- it's a
uniform bar because there's
no variable coefficient in
there and let me make it
a uniform load, just one.
So it actually shows you
that, I mentioned differential
equations and we'll certainly
get onto Laplace's equation,
but essentially our differential
equations will not--
this isn't a course in
how to solve ODEs or PDEs.
Especially not ODEs.
It's a course in how
to compute solutions.
So the key idea will be to
replace the differential
equation by a
difference equation.
So there's the
And I have to talk about that.
That's the sort of key
point, that-- up here you
see what I would call
a second difference.
Actually with a minus sign.
And on the right-hand side
you see the load, still f(x).
Can I move to this board
to explain differences?
Because this is
like, key step is
given the differential
equation replace it
by difference equation.
And the interesting point
is you have many choices.
There's one
differential equation
but even for a first
derivative, so this,
if you remember from
calculus, how did you
start with the derivative?
You started by something
before going to the limit.
h or delta x goes to zero in
the end to get the derivative.
But this was a
finite difference.
You moved a finite amount.
And this is the one you always
see in calculus courses.
u(x+h) - u(x), just how
much did that step go.
You divide by the
delta x, the h,
and that's approximately
the derivative, u'(x).
Let me just continue
with these others.
I don't remember if calculus
mentions a backward difference.
But you won't be surprised that
another possibility, equally
good more or less, would
be to take the point
and the point before, take the
difference, divide by delta x.
So again all these
approximate u'.
And now here's one that
actually is really important.
A center difference.
It's the average of
the forward and back.
If I take that plus that,
the u(x)'s cancel and I'm
left with, I'm centering it.
This idea of centering
is a good thing actually.
And of course I have to divide
by 2h because this step is now
2h, two delta x's.
So that again is
going to represent u'.
But so we have a choice if
we have a first derivative.
And actually that's a big issue.
You know, one might
be called upwind,
one might be called downwind,
one may be called centered.
It comes up constantly in aero,
in mechanical engineering,
everywhere.
You have these choices to make.
Especially for the
first difference.
We don't have, I didn't
allow a first derivative
in that equation because I
wanted to keep it symmetric
and first derivatives,
first differences
tend to be anti-symmetric.
So if we want to get
our good matrix K,
and I better remember
to divide by h squared,
because the K just has those
that I introduced last time
and will repeat, the K just
has the numbers -1, 2, -1.
Now, first point before we leave
these guys what's up with them?
How do we decide
which one is better?
There's something called
the order of accuracy.
How close is the difference
to the derivative?
And the answer is the
error is of size h.
So I would call that
first order accurate.
And I can repeat here
but the text does it,
how you recognize what-- This
is the sort of local error,
truncation error, whatever,
you've chopped off
the exact answer and
just did differences.
This one is also order h.
And in fact, the h
terms, the leading error,
which is going to
multiply the h,
has opposite sign in
these two and that's
the reason centered
differences are great.
Because when you average
them your center things--
this is correct to
order h squared.
And I may come back and find
out why that h squared term is.
Maybe I'll do that.
Yeah.
Why don't I just?
Second differences
are so important.
Why don't we just see.
And centered differences.
So let me see.
How do you figure u(x+h)?
This is a chance to remember
something called Taylor series.
But that was in calculus.
If you forgot it,
you're a normal person.
So but what does it say?
That's the whole point
of calculus, in a way.
That if I move a little
bit, I start from the point
x and then there's
a little correction
and that's given
by the derivative
and then there's a
further correction
if I want to go
further and that's
given by half of h squared,
you see the second order
correction, times the
second derivative.
And then, of course, more.
But that's all you
ever have to remember.
It's pretty rare.
Second order accuracy
is often the goal
in scientific computing.
First order accuracy is,
like, the lowest level.
You start there, you write a
code, you test it and so on.
But if you want production,
if you want accuracy,
get to second order if possible.
Now, what about this u(x-h)?
Well, that's a step
backwards, so that's u(x),
now the step is -h, but
then when I square that step
I'm back to +h^2
u''(x) and so on.
Ooh!
Am I going to find
even more accuracy?
I could tell you what
the next term is.
Plus h^3 upon 6, that's
3*2*1, u triple-prime.
And this would be, since
this step is -h now,
it would be -h^3 / 6 u'''.
So what happens when I take
the difference of these two?
Remember now that centered
differences subtract this
from this.
So now that u(x+h)
- u(x-h) is zero,
2hu' subtracting that from
that is zero, two of these,
so I guess that we really
have an h^3 / 3 u'''.
And now when I divide by the 2h,
can I just divide by 2h here?
Oh yeah, it's coming
out right, divide by 2h,
divide this by 2h, that'll
make it an h squared over six.
I've done what looks
like a messy computation.
I'm a little sad to start a
good lecture, important lecture
by such grungy stuff.
But it makes the key point.
That the centered difference
gives the correct derivative
with an error of order h^2.
Where the error for
the first differences,
the h would have been there.
And we can test it.
Actually we'll test it.
Okay for that?
This is first differences.
And that's a big
question: what do you
replace the first derivative
by if there is one?
And you've got
these three choices.
And usually this
is the best choice.
Now to second derivatives.
Because our equation
has got u'' in it.
So what's a second derivative?
It's the derivative
of the derivative.
So what's the second difference?
It's the difference,
first difference
of the first difference.
So the second difference,
the natural second difference
would be-- so now
let me use this space
for second differences.
Second differences.
I could take the
forward difference
of the backward difference.
Or I could take the
backward difference
of the forward difference.
Or you may say why don't I
take the centered difference
of the centered difference.
All those, in some sense
it's delta squared,
but which to take?
Well actually those are the
same and that's the good choice,
that's the 1, -2, 1 choice.
So let me show you that.
Let me say what's
the matter with that.
Because now having said how
great centered differences are,
first differences, why
don't I just repeat them
for second differences?
Well the trouble is, let me say
in a word without even writing,
well I could even write a
little, the center difference,
suppose I'm at a
typical mesh point here.
The center difference
is going to take
that value minus that value.
But then if I take the
center difference of that
I'm going to be out here.
I'm going to take this value,
this value, and this value.
I'll get something correct.
Its accuracy will be
second order, good.
But it stretches too far.
We want compact
difference molecules.
We don't want this one, minus
two of this, plus one of that.
So this would give
us a 1, 0, -2 , 0, 1.
I'm just saying this and then
I'll never come back to it
because I don't like
this one, these guys
give 1, -2, 1 without any gaps.
And that's the right choice.
And that's the choice made here.
So I'm not thinking you
can see it in your head,
that the difference
of the difference--
But well, you almost can.
If I take this, yeah.
Can you sort of see this
without my writing it?
If I take the forward
difference and then
I subtract the forward
difference to the left,
do you see that
I'll have minus two.
So there is what I started with.
I subtract u(x) - U(x-h) and I
get two -u(x)'s This is what I
get.
Now I'm calling that u_i.
I better make completely
clear about the minus sign.
The forward difference or
the backward difference,
what this leads is 1, -2, 1.
That's the second difference.
Very important to remember, the
second difference of a function
is the function, the value
ahead, minus two of the center,
plus one of the left.
It's centered obviously,
symmetric, right?
Second differences
are symmetric.
And because I want
a minus sign I
want minus the second
difference and that's
why you see here -1, 2, -1.
Because I wanted
positive two there.
Are you okay?
This is the natural
replacement for -u''.
And I claim that this
second difference
is like the second
derivative, of course.
And why don't we just
check some examples
to see how like the
second derivative it is.
So I'm going to take
the second difference
of some easy functions.
It's very important that
these come out so well.
So I'm going to take
the second difference.
I'm going to write it
as sort of a matrix.
So this is like the
second difference.
Yeah, because this is good.
I'm inside the region, here.
I'm not worried about
the boundaries now.
Let me just think
of myself as inside.
So I have second
differences and suppose
I'm applying it to a
vector of all ones.
What answer should I get?
So if I think of calculus, it's
the second derivative of one,
of the constant function.
So what answer am
I going to get?
Zero.
And do I get zero?
Of course.
I get zero.
Right?
All these second
differences are zero.
Because I'm not worrying
about the boundary yet.
So that's like, check one.
It passed that simple test.
Now let me move up from
constant to linear.
And so on.
So let me apply
second differences
to a vector that's
growing linearly.
What answer do I
expect to get for that?
So remember I'm doing
second differences,
like second
derivatives, or minus
second derivatives, actually.
So what do second derivatives
do to a linear function?
If I take a straight
line I take the-- sorry,
second derivatives.
If I take second derivatives
of a linear function I get?
Zero, right.
So I would hope to get
zero again here and I do.
Right?
-1+4-3=0.
Minus one, sorry, let
me do it here, -2+6-4.
And actually, that's consistent
with our little Taylor series
stuff.
The function x should
come out right.
Now what about-- now
comes the moment.
What about x squared?
So I'm going to
put squares in now.
Do I expect to get zeroes?
I don't think so.
Because let me again
test it by thinking
about what second derivative.
So now I'm sort of copying
second derivative of x squared,
which is?
Second derivative
of x squared is?
Two, right?
First derivative's 2x, second
derivative is just two.
So it's a constant.
And remember I put in a
minus sign so I'm wondering,
do I get the answer minus two?
All the way down.
-4+8-9.
Whoops.
What's that?
What do I get there?
What do I get from that second
difference of these squares?
-4+8-9 is?
Minus two, good.
So can we keep going?
-4+18-16.
What's that?
-4+18-16, so I've got -20+18.
I got minus two again.
-9, 32, -25, it's right.
The second differences
of the vector of squares,
you could say, is a constant
vector with the right number.
And that's because
that second difference
is second order accurate.
It not only got constants
right and linears right,
it got quadratics right.
So that's, you're seeing
second differences.
We'll soon see that second
differences are also
on the ball when you apply
them to other vectors.
Like vectors of sines or vectors
of cosines or exponentials,
they do well.
So that's just a useful check
which will help us over here.
Okay, can I come back to
the part of the lecture now?
Having prepared
the way for this.
Well, let's start right off
by solving the differential
equation.
So I'm bringing you back years
and years and years, right?
Solve that differential
equation with these two boundary
conditions.
How would you do that
in a systematic way?
You could almost
guess after a while,
but systematically
if I have a linear,
I notice-- What do I
notice about this thing?
It's linear.
So what am I expecting?
I'm expecting, like,
a particular solution
that gives the correct answer,
one, and some null space
solution or whatever
I want to call it,
homogeneous solution
that gives zero
and has some arbitrary
constants in it.
Give me a particular solution.
So this is going
to be our answer.
This'll be the general solution
to this differential equation.
What functions have minus the
second derivative equal one,
that's all I'm asking.
What are they?
So what is one of them?
One function that has its
second derivative is a constant
and that constant is minus one.
So if I want the second
derivative to be a constant,
what am I looking at? x squared.
I'm looking at x squared.
And I just want to
figure out how many x
squareds to get a one.
So some number of x squareds
and how many do I want?
-1/2, good.
Good.
-1/2.
Because x squared
would give me two
but I want minus
one so I need -1/2.
Okay that's the
particular solution.
Now throw in all the solutions,
I can add in any solution
that has a zero
on the right side,
so what functions have second
derivatives equals zero?
x is good.
I'm looking for two because
it's a second derivative, second
order equation.
What's the other guy?
Constant, good.
So let me put the constant
first, C, say, and Dx.
Two constants that I can
play with and what use
am I going to make of them?
I'm going to use those to
satisfy the two boundary
conditions.
And it won't be difficult.
You could say plug
in the first boundary
condition, get
an equation for the
constants, plug in
the second, got
another equation,
we'll have two
boundary conditions,
two equations, two constants.
Everything's going to come out.
So if I plug in u(0)=0,
what do I learn?
C is zero, right?
If I plug in, is that right?
If I plug in zero, then
that's zero already,
this is zero already, so I
just learned that C is zero.
So C is zero.
So I'm down to one constant,
one unused boundary condition.
Plug that in. u(1) = -1/2.
What's D?
It's 1/2, right.
D is 1/2.
So can I close this up?
There's 1/2.
Dx is 1/2.
Now it just always
pays to look back.
At x=0, that's obviously zero.
At x=1 it's zero because those
are the same and I get zero.
So -1/2 x squared plus 1/2 x.
That's the kind of differential
equation and solution
that we're looking for.
Not complicated nonlinear stuff.
So now I'm ready to move
to the difference equation.
So again, this is a major step.
I'll draw a picture of
this from zero to one.
And if I graph that I think
I get a parabola, right?
A parabola that has
to go through here.
So it's some parabola like that.
That would be always good, to
draw a graph of the solution.
Now, what do I get here?
Moving to the
difference equation.
So that's the equation, and
notice its boundary conditions.
Those boundary conditions
just copied this one
because I've chopped this up.
I've got i = 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, and this is one,
the last point then is 6h.
h is 1/6.
What's going to be
the size of my matrix
and my vector and
my unknown u here?
How many unknowns
am I going to have?
Let's just get the
overall picture right.
What are the
unknowns going to be?
They're going to be
u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4, u_5.
Those are unknown.
Those will be some
values, I don't
know where, maybe something
like this because they'll
be sort of like that one.
And this is not an unknown, u_6;
this is not an unknown, u_0;
those are the ones we know.
So this is what the solution
to a difference equation
looks like.
It gives you a discrete
set of unknowns.
And then, of course
MATLAB or any code
could connect them
up by straight lines
and give you a function.
But the heart of it
is these five values.
Okay, good.
And those five values
come from these equations.
I'm introducing
this subscript stuff
but I won't need it all the time
because you'll see the picture.
This equation applies for
i equal one up to five.
Five inside points and then
you notice how when i is one,
this needs u_0, but we know u_0.
And when i is five, this
needs u_6, but we know u_6.
So it's a closed
five by five system
and it will be our matrix.
That -1, 2, -1 is what
sits on the matrix.
When we close it with the
two boundary conditions
it chops off the
zero column, you
could say and chops
off the six column
and leaves us with a five
by five problem and yeah.
I guess this is a step not
to jump past because it
takes a little practice.
You see I've written
the same thing two ways.
Let me write it a third way.
Let me write it out clearly.
So now here I'm going to
complete this matrix with a two
and a minus one and a two and
a minus one and now it's five
by five.
And those might
be u, but I don't
know if they are, so let me put
in u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5.
Oh and divide by h squared.
I'll often forget that.
So I'm asking you
to see something
that if you haven't, after
you get the hang of it
it's like, automatic.
But I have to remember
it's not automatic.
Things aren't
automatic until you've
done them a couple of times.
So do you see that that is a
concrete statement of this?
This delta x squared
is the h squared.
And do you see those
differences when
I do that multiplication that
they produce those differences?
And now, what's my
right-hand side?
Well I've changed the right-hand
side to one to make it easy.
So this right-hand
side is all ones.
And this is the problem
that MATLAB would solve
or whatever code.
Find a difference code.
I've got to a linear
system, five by five,
it's fortunately-- the
matrix is not singular,
there is a solution.
How does MATLAB find it?
It does not find it by finding
the inverse of that matrix.
Monday's lecture
will quickly review
how to solve five equations
and five unknowns.
It's by elimination, I'll
tell you the key word.
And that's what every code does.
And sometimes you would
have to exchange rows,
but not for a positive
definite matrix like that.
It'll just go bzzz,
right through.
When it's tridiagonal it'll go
like with the speed of light
and you'll get the answer.
And those five answers will
be these five heights. u_1,
u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5.
And we could figure it out.
Actually I think section
1.2 gives the formula
for this particular model
problem for any size,
in particular for five by five.
And there is something
wonderful for this special case.
The five points fall right
on the correct parabola,
they're exactly right.
So for this particular case when
the solution was a quadratic,
the exact solution was
a quadratic, a parabola,
it will turn out-- and
that quadratic matches
these boundary conditions,
it will turn out
that those points are
right on the money.
So that's, you
could call, is like,
super-convergence or something.
I mean that won't
happen every time,
otherwise life would
be like, too easy.
It's a good life, but it's
not that good as a rule.
So they fall right
on that curve.
And we can say what
those numbers are.
Actually, we know what they are.
Actually, I guess
I could find them.
What are those numbers then?
And of course,
one over h squared
is-- What's one over h
squared, just to not forget?
One over h squared
there, h is what?
1/6.
Squared, it's going to be a 36.
So if I bring it up here,
bring the h squared up here,
it would be times a 36.
Well let me leave it here, 36.
And I'm just saying that these
numbers would come out right.
Maybe I'll just
do the first one.
What's the exact u_1, u_2?
u_1 and u_2 would be what?
The exact u_1, ooh!
Oh shoot, I've got
to figure it out.
If I plug in x=1/6...
Do we want to do this?
Plug in x=1/6?
No, we don't.
We don't.
We've got something better
to do with our lives.
But if we put that
number in, whatever
the heck it is, in this one, we
would find out came out right.
The fact that it comes
out right is important.
But I'd like to move on
to a similar problem.
But this one is going
to be free-fixed.
So if this problem was like
having an elastic bar hanging
under its own weight
and these would
be the displacements points on
the bar and fixed at the ends,
now I'm freeing up the top end.
I'm not making u_0 zero anymore.
I better maybe use a
different blackboard
because that's so important
that I don't want to erase it.
So let me take the same problem,
uniform bar, uniform load,
but I'm going to fix
u(1), that's fixed,
but I'm going to free this end.
And from a differential
equation point of view,
that means I'm going to set
the slope at zero to be zero.
u'(0)=0.
That's going to have
a different solution.
Change the boundary conditions
is going to change the answer.
Let's find the solution.
So here's another
differential equation.
Same equation, different
boundary conditions,
so how do we go?
Well I had the general
solution over there.
It still works, right? u(x)
is still -1/2 of x squared.
The particular solution
that gives me the one.
Plus the Cx plus D that
gives me zero and zero
for second derivatives
but gives me
the possibility to satisfy
the two boundary conditions.
And now again, plug in
the boundary conditions
to find C and D.
Slope is 0 at 0.
What does that tell me?
I have to plug that in.
Here's my solution, I have
to take its derivative
and set x to zero.
So its derivative
is a 2x or a minus x
or something which is zero.
The derivative of that is C and
the derivative of that is zero.
What am I learning from
that left, the free boundary
condition?
C is zero, right?
C is zero because
the slope here is C
and it's supposed to be zero.
So C is zero.
Now the other
boundary condition.
Plug in x=1.
I want to get the answer zero.
The answer I do get is -1/2 at
x=1, plus D. So what is D then?
What's D?
Let me raise that.
What do I learn about D?
It's 1/2.
I need 1/2.
So the answer is -1/2
of x squared plus 1/2.
Not 1/2 x as it was
over there, but 1/2.
And now let's graph it.
Always pays to
graph these things
between x equals zero and one.
What does this looks like?
It starts at 1/2, right?
At x=0.
And it's a parabola, right?
It's a parabola.
And I know it goes
through this point.
What else do I know?
Slope starts at?
The slope starts at zero.
The other, the
boundary condition,
the free condition
at the left-hand end,
so slope starts at zero, so the
parabola comes down like that.
It's like half
a-- where that was
a symmetric bit of a parabola,
this is just half of it.
The slope is zero.
And so that's a graph of u(x) .
Now I'm ready to replace it
by a difference equation.
So what'll be the
difference equation?
It'll be the same
equation for the -u''.
No change.
So minus u_(i+1) minus 2u_i,
minus u_(i-1) over h squared
equals-- I'm taking f(x) to be
one, so let's stay with one.
Okay, big moment.
What boundary conditions?
Well, this guy is pretty clear.
That says u_(n+1) is zero.
What do I do for zero slope?
What do I do for a zero slope?
Okay, let me suggest
one possibility.
It's not the greatest, but one
possibility for zero slope is
(u_1-u_0)/h -- that's
the approximate slope --
should be zero.
So that's my choice for the
left-hand boundary condition.
It says u_1 is u_0 .
It says that u_1 is u_0 .
So now I've got
again five equations
for five unknowns, u_1,
u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5.
I'll write down what they are.
Well, you know what they are.
So this thing
divided by h squared
is all ones, just like before.
And of course all these
rows are not changed.
But the first row is changed
because we have a new boundary
condition at the left end.
And it's this.
So u_1, well u_0
isn't in the picture,
but previously what
happened to u_0, when
i is one, I'm in the
first equation here,
that's where I'm
looking. i is one.
It had a u_0.
Gone.
In this case it's not gone.
u_0 comes back in, u_0 is u_1.
That might-- Ooh!
Don't let me do this wrong.
Ah!
Don't let me do it worse!
All right.
There we go.
Good.
Okay.
Please, last time I
videotaped lecture 10
had to fix up lecture 9,
because I don't go in.
Professor Lewin in the
physics lectures, he cheats,
doesn't cheat, but he goes
into the lectures afterwards
and fixes them.
But you get exactly
what it looks like.
So now it's fixed, I hope.
But don't let me screw up.
So now, what's on this top row?
When i is one.
I have minus u_2, that's fine.
I have 2u_1 as before,
but now I have a minus
u_1 because u_0 and
u_1 are the same.
So I just have a one in there.
That's our matrix that we called
T. The top row is changed,
the top row is free.
This is the equation T
times u divided by h squared
is the right-hand side, ones.
ones(5), I would call that.
Properly I would
call it ones(5, 1),
because the MATLAB command
'ones' wants matrix
and it's a matrix with
five rows, one column.
But it's T, that's
the important thing.
And would you like to guess
what the solution looks like?
In particular, is it
again exactly right?
Is it right on the money?
Or if not, why not?
The computer will
tell us, of course.
It will tell us whether we
get agreement with this.
This is the exact solution here
and this is the exact parabola
starting with zero slope.
So but I solved this problem.
Oh, let me see, I didn't get
u_1, u_2 to u_5 in there.
So it didn't look right.
u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4, and u_5.
And that's the right-hand side.
Sorry about that.
So that's T divided
by h squared.
T, with that top row changed,
times U is the right-hand side.
By the way, I
better just say what
was the reason that we came out
exactly right on this problem?
Would we come out exactly right
if it was some general load
f(x)?
No.
Finite differences
can't do miracles.
They have no way to know
what's happening to f(x)
between the mesh points, right?
If I took this to be f(x) and
took this at the five points,
at these five
points, this wouldn't
know what f(x) is in between,
couldn't be exactly right.
It's exactly right in
this lucky special case
because, of course,
it has the right ones.
But also because, the
reason it's exactly right
is that second differences of
quadratics are exactly right.
That's what we checked on this
board that's underneath there.
Second differences of
squares came out perfectly.
And that's why the second
differences of this guy
give the right
answer, so that guy
is the answer to both the
differential and the difference
equation.
I had to say that word about
why was that exactly right.
It was exactly right because
second differences of squares
are exactly right.
Now, again, we have second
differences of squares.
So you could say
exactly right or no?
What are you betting?
How many think, yeah, it's going
to come out on the parabola?
Nobody.
Right.
Everybody thinks there's
something going to miss here.
And why?
Why am I going to
miss something?
Yes?
It's a first-order approximation
at the left boundary.
Exactly right, exactly right.
It's a first-order
approximation to take this
and I'm not going
to get it right.
That first-order approximation,
that error of size h
is going to penetrate
over the whole interval.
It'll be biggest here.
Actually I think it turns
out, and the book has a graph,
I think it comes out
wrong by 1/2 h there.
1/2 h, first order.
And then it, of
course, it's discrete
and of course it's straight
across because that's
the boundary condition, right?
And then it starts down, it gets
sort of closer, closer, closer
and gets, of course,
that's right at the end.
But there's an error.
The difference between u, the
true u, and the computed u
is of order h.
So you could say alright, if h
is small I can live with that.
But as I said in
the end you really
want to get second order
accuracy if you can.
And in a simple
problem like this
we should be able to do it.
What I've done already
covers section 1.2
but then there's a
note, a worked example
at the end of 1.2 that tells you
how to upgrade to second order.
And maybe we've got a moment
to see how would we do it.
What would you suggest
that I do differently?
I'll get a different matrix.
I'll get a different
discrete problem.
But that'll be okay.
I can solve that just as well.
And what shall I
replace that by?
because that was the
guilty party, as you said.
That was guilty.
That's only a first
order approximation
to zero slope at zero.
A couple of ways we could go.
This is a correct second
order approximation
at what mesh point?
That is a correct second order
approximation to u'=0, but not
at that point or at
that point where?
Halfway between.
If I was looking
at a point halfway
between that, that
would be centered there,
that would be a
centered difference
and it would be good.
But we're not looking there.
So I'm looking here.
So what do you suggest I do?
Well I've got to center it.
Essentially I'm
going to use u_(-1).
I'm going to use u_(-1).
And let me just say
what the effect is.
You remember we started with
the usual second difference
here, 2, -1, -1.
This is what got chopped
off for the fixed method.
It got brought back here
by our first order method.
Our second order
method will-- You
see what's likely to happen?
That minus one is
going to show up where?
Over here.
To center it around zero.
So that guy will make
this into a minus two.
Now that matrix is still fine.
It's not one of our
special matrices.
When I say fine, it's
not beautiful is it?
It's got one, like,
flaw, it needs
what do you call it when
you have your face--
cosmetic surgery or something.
It needs a small improvement.
So what's the matter with it?
It's not symmetric.
It's not symmetric
and a person isn't
happy with a un-symmetric
problem, approximation
to a perfectly symmetric thing.
So I could just divide
that row by two.
If I divide that row by 2, which
you won't mind if I do that,
make that one, minus
one and makes this 1/2.
I divided the first
equation by two.
Look in the notes in
the text if you can.
And the result is
now it's right on.
It's exactly on.
Because again, the solution,
the true solution is squares.
This is now second order and
we'll get it exactly right.
And I say all this
for two reasons.
One is to emphasize again that
the boundary conditions are
critical and that they
penetrate into the region.
The second reason
for my saying this
is looking forward
way into October.
So let me just say the
finite element method, which
you may know a little about,
you may have heard about,
it's another-- this
was finite differences.
Courses starting with
finite differences,
because that's the
most direct way.
You just go for it.
You've got derivatives, you
replace them by differences.
But another approach which turns
out to be great for big codes
and also turns out to
be great for making,
for keeping the properties of
the problem, the finite element
method, you'll see it, it's
weeks away, but when it comes,
notice, the finite element
method automatically
produces that first equation.
Automatically gets it right.
So that's pretty special.
And so, the finite
element method just has,
it produces that
second order accuracy
that we didn't get automatically
for finite differences.
Okay, questions on today
or on the homework.
So the homework is
really wide open.
It's really just a
chance to start to see.
I mean, the real homework
is read those two sections
of the book to capture what
these two lectures have done.
So Monday I'll see.
We'll do elimination.
We'll solve these equations
quickly and then move on
to the inverse matrix.
More understanding
of these problems.
Thanks.